who is a prominent democrat that's a  communist  wow that's a good one um  you know those four radical women that  uh  who are those stupid women  the one from new york and detroit what  what yeah the squad those are a  perfect example of communism i can't  think of their name they're so stupid  so they and and  the cortez i believe from new york  that's a nut case i don't even  understand why anyone would even listen  to her right less more vote for her but  you have the other one out of  what  illihan omar and another one  and what uh what communists  what communist policy have they  advocated for  they want to take care of the people  they want to take care of the people  ain't for the people they want to get  free health care free everything for the  folks